hey guys it's melanie from
melaniekayham.com welcome back to my
channel today's video we're going to
make
a daisy crochet granny square youtube
star melanie ham has died she was 36.
i'd love to see what you guys make what
color background are you going to pick
melanie's husband robert announced on
instagram that she died january 12th
following her battle with cancer he
writes in the caption quote it is with a
heavy heart and deep sadness i share the
news of the passing of my sweet amazing
beautiful wife melanie if you've been
following our journey i'm sure you were
like us hopeful she could defeat this
insidious disease since we discovered
that the tumor i had
on my kidney
about a year and a half ago
came back
and so it came back in multiple
locations in my belly and so i had a
big surgery big big surgery to um
try and get rid of some of those though
melanie died just nine days before the
couple's 16th anniversary robert insists
melanie fought like a warrior queen from
the scan results it's just like you know
the fear is a real thing anxiety is a
real thing and so i'm feeling much
lighter and able to sort of just
breathe a little bit the youtube star
known for her knitting quilting and
crocheting tutorials has nearly 1
million subscribers on her channel we're
going to make this crochet scarf it's
nice and wide it's kind of like a
statement scarf like whoa i'm wearing a
scarf and it's so warm and cozy the
crafting pro also shared many diy videos
today i am going to be showing you how
to make a macrame
wine tote the only thing bigger than
melanie's talent her heart we are here
to visit a sewing group
maria del carmen has started a group of
about 20 women who are single moms and
they are earning their own income by
sewing that's melanie and honduras
spending time with single moms who like
her so for a living join me in helping
to spread love and to spread assistance
to the people of honduras and to these
communities who need it so desperately
in august 2020 melanie began sharing her
health journey with her followers after
announcing she had a cancerous tumor the
last couple weeks i've been having some
issues with my health and it turns out
that that mass
[Music]
has come back
so
it was a benign mass but now it's not
the mother of two continued keeping fans
up to date on her surgeries and cancer
treatment this video is to just say
thank you so much for all the prayers
and well wishes
i certainly felt them as i've been
recovering and i'm just so so thankful
for this community thank you guys so
much for rallying behind me i really
really appreciate it as robert and the
couple's two children continue to mourn
they will also celebrate melanie's life
will be honored at an upcoming memorial
where colorful clothing is encouraged
[Music]
you